i think that's so true i think that the
reason like i don't know if you've done
have you gotten to this point where you
can feel body resonance with yeses and
no's especially guesses
like my body gets the chills like it's i
say oh i got goosebumps but then i look
and i'm like i don't actually have
goosebumps i think it's just electricity
i think it's just electricity i think my
chakras light up my body sends like
there's there's like a it's like a
resonant yes like frequency wise
and it's a great really good indicator
has that have you figured has that come
to you
yeah like words touch me more than
more than a physical touch you see what
i say like like
i could be hugged by a million people
and feel
nothing but a sentence like let that
bird speak
is like the whole world
touching me you know that's when i truly
feel and like that's like
you know we have our our basic senses
and um
one of them is touch but like there's
also feel
and i think that once we once we evolve
a little more you get that extra sense
which is feel
and it's feel without touch and you know
that's that's really where i like to
reside in it's like
i know the power like like
it it seems it seems so
undefinable but like really i know the
power of like
a sentence man i know how much something
can change your life like
the course of your entire life can be
changed by someone speaking to you and
really
giving a [ __ ] about you and like i think
that's like
what really does it for me is like i
meet people in my life
that i can tell really give a [ __ ] about
me and like those
are the type of things that like really
bring me to absolute tears
like to my you might come out right now
because i'm thinking about people that
actually care about me and like
truly love me and like you know that
that to me like this to me is bravery
is being able to be like it's
fearlessness it's being like like
dude i love the fact that
i can be i can be saved at any moment
you know and there's so many things
outside this world that are like
[ __ ] man you know my life changes every
single day lately like i'm on this like
serious inc
like my whole career has been like this
but now it's it's breaking it's bending
like this it's like
and going through the roof dude and like
you know i'm getting these things that
i've always dreamed about like
like in terms of success that you think
about and it's like you think your life
is going to change like drastically when
you get this like monetary value of
things and
and and success that you've since 16
been like
dude all i want to do is like become a
millionaire
or like [ __ ] be able to take care of
my family like all that [ __ ]
and it's like you know what i'm so
changed by a sentence and not at all by
those things
those things don't change me the things
that change me are really like
these relationships that i've created
this power that i hold within myself to
be able to like
you know try to be a leader
if anything you know try to be a leader
and that that it's just those are the
things that like i can hold close to me
and like what you were saying about like
just like the getting goosebumps it's
like once you like really get to that
place it's like
you're perpetually there you're
perpetually there and like
you're not only like waiting for them to
come you're looking at them dead in the
eyes you're looking at everything like
holy [ __ ] that that's changing that's
affecting you
all of this right here without just
waiting for it to come
you're accepting it and just looking at
it right in the eyes and like this
conversation that i've had with you over
the last hour is like
something that like i know is
restoring like even more faith like like
you are an incredible human being you
really
are and like i can feel it just looking
at like we could stop talking
and me and you just continued the
conversation you know i feel that with
you
and god damn it we're lucky that that
this type of [ __ ]
exists you live there you live and feel
land
yeah and in fact you know and maybe this
is something for people that have
addiction and have um ways of trying to
escape reality
is that is hearing this is that
you know you live in the land of feel
and until you really
so so a lot of times what happens is
people numb it not because they can't
feel like some like feel no point or
pointlessness or enough it's you feel
too much you actually feel
too much and so you have to shut it off
because you don't know where to start
and like it's it's a it's an
overwhelming thing and so you know
for for for you to finally be in that
place where you can really truly express
and is that where the music comes in you
know loving poetry loving words
is that why music became your thing
great guy another great question um
when it hits just right
that's my ultimate drug the ultimate
drug is when that volume is going on
and these chords are happening and these
sounds you know we're only given
12 notes in a scale and we're reusing
these 12
[ __ ] notes over and over
i mean quincy jones said it [ __ ]
point blank was like
we got 12 notes we keep using them over
and over and we're coming up with new
things
like how how
unexplainable